Hi, Mystery Recapped here.
Today I am going to explain a science-fiction
drama film called “LX 2048.”
Spoilers ahead!
Watch out and take care!
The movie begins with a scene from the near
future where a natural calamity known as the
'heat up' has caused people to stay indoors.
This phenomenon was caused by the continuous
blazing heat of the sun.
Because of the inhumane conditions, people
are utilizing a replica of themselves to operate
outdoors.
While the replica is sent to do the work outside,
people have become dormant as they have nothing
to do inside their houses.
Hence, they have acquired mental diseases.
Lithium X is the only medicine that can help
them be normal as it can help people stay
in shape by providing Vitamin D.
Next, we are introduced to Adam Bird, the
lead character of the movie.
He is one of the few living humans to wake
up early and to go to work.
One day after visiting a doctor, he gets to
know that he is going to die soon.
A devastated Adam inquires with the doctor
as to whether he has any other options for
survival.
The doctor responds that he can only survive
if someone donates his heart.
The doctor also considers him fortunate after
learning that he has an insurance plan from
"Premium 3" that will cover his children's
education and upbringing after his death.
Adam inquires whether he may utilize the Premium
3 insurance to get a healthy heart clone,
but the doctor responds that it is only feasible
if his wife agrees to the terms.
When Adam hears this, he expresses his dissatisfaction
with his present relationship with his wife,
which is on the verge of divorce.
Adam also finds out that the doctor he is
talking to is a clone itself which is unharmed
by the rays of the sun.
He further despises how much the present society
seems to be submerged in technology.
After analyzing Adam's vulnerable mental state,
the doctor arranges for him to see a psychiatrist.
In the following scene, Adam is shown wearing
a VR headset and talking to his wife Reena.
He curses his wife during their talk since
she doesn't seem to mind and care for the
fact that he is dying and she also refuses
to see him face to face.
Adam pities himself for loving his wife in
the first place and hangs up the phone.
Afterwards, Adam dresses up in a hazmat suit
and drives his car in the scorching sun to
his vacant workplace.
Here, we can see that the rest of his coworkers
have chosen to work from home.
It seems like he works for a tech firm that
specializes in VR manufacture and production.
He is alone in the entire office, sitting
around the conference table, arguing with
his coworkers virtually.
He advises his boss to avoid investing in
virtual reality headsets and instead focus
on the creation and research of a technology
dubbed CHIP, which he says will soon replace
VR.
Later, Adam exits his office and goes to the
psychiatrist for his planned appointment.
At the psychiatrist’s office, Adam describes
his feeling of being a lone human strolling
outside in the sweltering heat.
However, the present doctor also appears to
be a clone.
When Adam notices this, he exclaims that although
the clones have all the skills as the original
ones, they lack a feeling of compassion and
emotions.
The movie then cuts to an incident that occurred
months ago.
Adam reaches home after work and finds his
children playing games and enjoying the virtual
world.
He then sees his wife relaxing in the virtual
sunbath in her room.
After a long day at work, he engages himself
in virtual sexual intercourse with a doll
which gives simulations like real intercourse.
During the climax of the scene, his wife Reena
appears in the room.
Adam apologizes to her for not locking the
door.
However, an angry Reena accuses him of cheating
on her with his online girlfriend.
Adam tries to explain the awkward situation
to her but she ignores him and walks out.
This was the incident that ignited their hostile
relationship.
Back in the present, Adam wakes up and grooms
himself for the meeting that he has planned
with his family.
When he reaches home, Reena refuses to meet
him.
Frustrated, he calls Reena virtually from
the main entrance and threatens to break through
the door.
Finally, Reena accepts to meet him outside
but shows no sadness or sympathy for the fact
that he is dying.
Adam tries to explain to her that he should
be alive to make the family live happily in
the future and to overcome their expenses.
But Reena adamantly answers that she will
cover all the expenses including his clone
with the help of Premium 3.
Adam tells her that his company is near to
bankruptcy and the family will not get any
insurance benefit if he dies at the moment.
Despite Adam’s explanation, Reena refuses
to use Premium 3 for the clone of his heart
and suggests he use Lithium X so that he would
get enough time to save his bankrupt company.
She literally does not care if he dies or
lives.
The next day, Adam is seen calling the retirement
home to speak with a man named Donald Stein
but gets no answer.
After that, he gets stressed and calls his
AI girlfriend named Maria.
Maria seems to be concerned that he is crying
and tries to comfort him.
Despite the fact that Adam knows Maria has
been programmed to make him feel good, he
still believes that she loves her.
He lies on his bed, listening to the dream
of Maria being with him.
Suddenly he wakes up to Donald pointing a
gun at him.
Donald asks Adam how he knows about him and
about the Chip technology.
Adam explains that he tried to call him earlier
as he believes that he is the creator of the
Chip technology.
Adam then asks for Donald’s help to save
his company along with his family.
Adam then goes into a flashback and remembers
a clerk named Dennis Ryan, congratulating
him and Reena for having three kids.
3 kids at that time was very rare as the population
was declining and people were barely getting
married and having intercourse.
The clerk then proposes to them an insurance
policy called “Premium 3”, which would
help them to clone their lost family members.
The clerk also reveals that it is developed
by the chief genetic engineer Donald Stein.
Reena seems excited about the proposal but
Adam looks skeptical.
Back in the present, Adam tells Donald that
he found him with the help of his dental records
and also praises him for being the father
of human cloning.
Donald laughs at his words but nods in agreement
telling him that the augmented pigmentation
of the brain is not possible without using
the CHIP.
After a few drinks, Donald opens up and says
that after the big heat up, he was assigned
by the state to clone humans who were not
affected by the sun.
Adam expresses his hate toward the idea of
cloning humans and wants to get accepted for
who he is.
Donald then mentions that he also found his
true love in his virtual girlfriend.
The movie again cuts to the scene where Adam
and Reena are fighting after she found Adam
having a virtual girlfriend.
Reena is disgusted by the fact that a virtual
girl is able to satisfy him better than she
could.
After their argument, Reena suggests that
their relationship would only work if Adam
deletes his virtual girlfriend.
Adam refuses, and their relationship ends.
In the present, both Donald and Adam are now
connected to each other at another level after
a night of drinking and smoking together.
Donald claims that he can build a clone heart
for Adam.
He also adds that the pain Adam is feeling
is emotional rather than physiological and
concludes that his heart is normal.
Adam is feeling pain for the reason of not
taking Lithium X. Donald accepts the fact
that he too created the clone of his virtual
girlfriend for satisfaction.
He then purchased his freedom by selling the
patents of the technology of creating the
chip.
For the sake of the bond they have formed,
Donald promises to help Adam by creating a
clone of his virtual girlfriend Maria.
The next morning, Adam calls his mother and
feels weird about her avatar which she created
to be significantly younger.
His mother asks him if he takes Lithium X
regularly.
On hearing this, Adam expresses his hatred
towards the drug.
He then notices his hand being burnt by the
sun and immediately covers the windows.
Late at night, Reena pays him a visit and
inquires about his well-being.
She is there with a plan to gain access to
Premium 3's privileges without Adam's death.
She explains to him the idea of virtual assassination,
and also mentions that someone she knows will
create the paperwork required for the state
to approve his death.
Adam is shocked to hear it and asks Reena
what is going to happen to him.
Reena suggests him to do whatever he feels
like and also expresses that she has no problem
if he wants to be with Maria.
At first, Adam refuses to accept her offer
but after knowing how much his wife hates
him, Adam reluctantly agrees to do it.
Reena then informs him that she has already
done it and kisses him.
Reena then hands him his new ID and his credentials
but Adam is worried about the fact that he
can no longer talk to his girlfriend Maria
as he is not Adam Bird anymore.
His new name is found to be Richard Burbage.
Reena apologizes for changing his identity
and also assures him that she will urge the
cloned Adam not to delete Maria.
When Reena is about to return back, a van
hits her, killing her instantly.
After some time, Police and paramedics arrive
at the scene.
One of the officers reaches out to Adam and
expresses his condolences and also suggests
he see a therapist.
He goes through Adams’s profile and finds
out that they are on a Premium 3 insurance
plan.
He assures him that a better version of Reena
will arrive within some days and will take
care of the children.
Following the officer's departure, Adam returns
to his room and attempts to get into his account,
only to discover that all of his credentials
have been changed.
A nervous Adam then makes himself puke to
get rid of the booze in his system.
After a while, he notices that someone is
at the door.
When he reaches out, he discovers Maria, who
starts kissing him passionately.
Adam is taken aback and can't take his gaze
away from Maria, as she is the girl of his
fantasies.
He wants to be intimate with her, but Maria
mentions that she is still undergoing Donald's
tests.
After some time, Adam discovers that Donald
had made love to Maria before transferring
her to his house.
Adam overreacts and Maria advises him to calm
down.
She also tells him that she has the right
to look into other possibilities.
Later, Adam notices Maria showering.
He then walks out into the living room and
begins searching Maria's handbag.
Inside, he discovers protection and a transparent
chip.
After Maria is done showering, Adam confronts
her about the chip.
She responds that the chip can download and
transmit the complete brain of a dying person
to the virtual world.
Adam is taken aback when he learns that a
single chip may hold a whole person.
Adam stares at Maria, both impressed and terrified.
As she intends to leave, Adam begs her to
stay with him.
However, Maria rejects, claiming that her
body's cells are organized to fall in love
but not with him.
Following Maria's departure, a giddy Adam
dances with the pleasure doll that Maria once
was.
He then looks at the doll with enraged eyes
and begins stabbing it with a knife multiple
times.
In the next scene, Adam is seen lying in a
corner, with his body trembling.
A ring at the door awakens him up from his
gloomy state and he crawls to the door, only
to be greeted by Reena's idealized version
of himself.
The cloned Adam talks about their wife’s
death with a cooler attitude and appearance.
He then begins to judge the real Adam based
on his appearance and the state of his house.
He also tells him that he would not harm him
because he was created to only use violence
in self-defense.
Clone Adam praises Reena and says that she
is a great woman but the real Adam can't see
it because of his ignorance.
All this while, the real Adam is shocked to
see the clone’s appearance.
He then asks clone Adam to strip in front
of him to check his body structure.
After witnessing all of this, the real Adam
begins ranting and blaming Donald for his
current state.
He also inquires about clone Adam's opinions
on assassinating Donald.
Real Adam is irritated by the fact that the
cloned Adam is better at everything than him.
The clone expresses sympathy for the real
Adam and requests that he embrace his new
life.
This annoys the real Adam and he carries a
gun with him.
Clone Adam then follows real Adam to the room
he enters, saying that he should be able to
accept the changes happening in society.
He also predicts that in the not-too-distant
future, everyone will migrate to the digital
realm.
Real Adam then recalls the fact that he can't
be alive in a world where another Adam exists,
so he points the gun at the clone.
In an attempt to save himself, the clone reminds
Adam why Reena replaced him.
He then remembers that he is dying.
Clone Adam then suggests real Adam take the
Lithium X pill in order to call him down.
As he is about to do so, he recovers from
the manipulation and aims the gun at clone
Adam.
The defense mechanism of the clone kicks in
and the gun slips off real Adams’s hand
and drops to the table, making the gun fire
right through the forehead of real Adam.
In the next scene, cloned Adam is burying
the real Adam.
After returning home, he takes some time to
pick from the two sets of clothes.
Finally, the clone of Reena also appears at
the door and the two of them connect with
each other in no time.
Inside the house, the two of them share an
intimate moment and also plan to replace their
kids with smarter ones with the help of Premium
3.
Subscribe for more videos like this, turn
on the notification, and leave a like to help
the channel out.
Thank You for watching.